in the part 1 video we already saw james
madison and federalist number 10 argue
strongly that a republican form of
government is better for addressing the
issues of having a majority faction that
might try to overrun minority groups
in this video we're going to continue to
see that argument that not only is a
republic better but if you're going to
have a republic it's better to have a
large republic
in the next place as each representative
will be chosen by a greater number of
citizens in the large the larger public
than in the small republic it will be
more difficult for unworthy candidates
to practice with success the vicious
arts by which elections are too often
carried and the suffrages of the people
being more free will be more likely to
center in men who possess the most
attractive merit once again elite
democracy and the most diffusive and
established characters once again elite
democracy so here he's making the
argument that not only in a large
republic will you have a better choice
of candidates but because the candidates
have to appeal each to a large number of
people that they're less likely to to
come to power through shady dealings and
you're most likely to get the best folks
it must be confessed that in this as in
most other cases there is a mean on both
sides of which inconveniences will be
found to lie
so you're saying hey look there's as in
all things there's kind of a moderate
middle ground by enlarging too much the
number of electors you render the
representatives too little acquainted
with all their local circumstances and
lesser interests as by reducing it too
much you render him unduly attached to
these and too little fit to comprehend
and pursue great and national objects
the federal constitution forms a happy
combination in this respect
the great and aggregate interests being
referred to the national the local and
particular to the state legislatures so
what he's saying is that the
constitution offers this really nice
balance here you can have the people
participating at the national level who
are interested in the great and
aggregate interests and it's okay if
those folks aren't completely attached
to what is happening at home the local
interests in fact he'd probably prefer
that they're not attached too much to
the local interests but the local
interests could be focused at the state
legislatures which the constitution
provides for
the other point of difference so once
again he's referring to the difference
between a republican government and a
pure democracy the greater number of
citizens in the extent of territory
which may be brought within the compass
of a republican then of democratic
government so it's that point that he
believes the republican government can
better govern a large population than a
pure democracy and it is this
circumstance principally which renders
the factious combinations less to be
dreaded in the former than in the latter
so he's saying because a republican
model can govern over more people it
better addresses this issue of factious
combinations
the smaller the society the fewer
probably will be the distinct parties
and interests composing it the fewer the
distinct parties and interests the more
frequently will a majority be found of
the same party and the smaller the
number of individuals composing a
majority and the smaller the compass
within which they are placed the more
easily will they concert and execute
their plans of oppression
extend the sphere and you take in a
greater variety of parties and interests
you make it less probable that a
majority of the whole will have a common
motive to invade the rights of other
citizens what madison is saying here is
if you have too small of a society
you're not going to have enough
pluralism you're not going to have
enough points of view that it'll be easy
because people will be very aligned for
a majority to take over and infringe on
the rights of a minority so he is very
pro-pluralism here he wants to see a
large society with many different views
because he says if you have a large
society with many different views with
many different parties so to speak well
it's less likely that one party can just
take over and infringe on the rights of
other people this is the exact opposite
of what brutus 1 argues for brutus 1
argues that pluralism is a bad thing
that people are just going to be
bickering the whole time and decisions
aren't going to be made brutus 1 argues
that in a republic people should be of
roughly the same opinion to have roughly
the same interests while here in
federalist number 10 madison is arguing
that no pluralism is a good thing it is
a check on an overbearing faction it is
a check on majority rule
hence it clearly appears that the same
advantage which a republic has over a
democracy
in controlling the effects of faction is
enjoyed by a large over a small republic
is enjoyed by the union over the states
composing it so the big picture of
federalist number 10 is how do you
control faction and faction is really
about how do you control a majority
faction that's trying to control
everyone else and trying to oppress
everyone else madison makes the argument
that one through a republican system
you're more likely to do this by having
a representative government and then if
you have that you want to make it larger
rather than smaller so that you have a
pluralist society so you have many
points of view and you don't have one
group being able to dominate and in
order to have that larger society the
union is more favorable over having 13
independent sovereign states
in the extent and proper structure of
the union therefore we behold a
republican remedy for the diseases most
incident to republican government and
according to the degree of pleasure and
pride we feel in being republicans ought
to be our zeal and cherishing the spirit
and supporting the character of
federalists